françois bellefeuille commençons par
l'éléphant dans la pièce éthique au
bordel deux semaines les humoristes se
sont réunis pour parler de la sphère
rozon vous commandez avait réagi sur le
coup c'est extrêmement difficile parce
que tu écoutes que les victimes disent
tu réalises que mlle j'ai dit à mon rêve
quand j'étais petit juste pour rire
depuis tout petit je regarde ça c'est
pour moi l'on vient de m'enlever sais je
veux dire je veux regarder la première
fois que j'ai fait un gala juste pour
rire à tes lippi je vois tout le temps à
regarder avec un petit goût amer
maintenant qu'ils venaient de gilbert
rozon
oui moi ça va changer ma manière de voir
ça mais surtout c'est ma mentalité
la mentalité du milieu est en train de
changer puis c'est tellement beau quand
barça le milieu était pas plus pourri
parce que d'autres gens je suis certain
c'est juste que cette année ça nous
arrive à nous devant tout le monde nous
regarde en même temps
ben on a eu le courage de se regarder de
se parler c'est pas fini on va se
positionner ensemble et non
individuellement j'ai réfléchi beaucoup
à la question j'ai pas fini de réfléchir
et je peux garantir que à partir de
maintenant dans le futur je suis plus
outillés pour protéger mon milieu pour
favoriser le fait que les victimes aient
le courage de parler puisqu'il se passe
en ce moment juste beau mais ça fait mal
un vrai vent de la faire avec salvail a
fait aussi couler beaucoup d'encre parce
que c'est aussi ça a changé votre
perception certaines choses ils veulent
indice de bollène éric salvail jeu on le
voyait agir je le savais qu'il était
comme ça je savais pas qui était aussi
grave que ce jeu mais je dois avouer que
ce n'est plus comme maintenant mais
j'avais un préjugé par rapport à ça je
me disais que c'était quasiment un petit
peu plus correct je prenais certaines
personnes qui ont fait partie des
plaintes contre et et je leur ai parlé
après une personne et j'ai compris
l'emploi de commun que seul avait
affecté encore une fois l'histoire
d'eric je trouve ça très sérieux il y
avait un côté de moi qui avais le goût
de vanille
banalisée ça un petit peu un peu que
plus que je le fais maintenant juste
parce que c'étaient des hommes je vais
je sais pas j'avais l'impression que ça
se faisait souvent comme ça la cruze
homosexuels en deux ans au brésil
je m'étais trompé totalement j'ai changé
en moins de deux semaines mon opinion
sur le sujet de manière importante
puis j'étais déjà selon moins quelqu'un
qui était dans la bonne direction
puis j'en parle avec les gens quand je
fais mes spectacles maintenant j'en ai
parlé beaucoup avec mes compatriotes me
reste pis le milieu est en train de
changer la société est en train de
changer
si tu te demandes deuxième one man show
c'est le plus fort françois maintenant
parlons si vous le voulez bien de votre
prochain spectacle
oui mon prochain spectacle si mon fils
de 2,5 trouver la diète
je dépends sur vos débuts ça laisse
l'idée de quelqu'un qui mange du sable
après avoir bondi trois cent mille
billets way comment on se prépare pour
un la suite c'est ma grande force c'est
que j'aime sourire de moi j'ai pas peur
de rire de moi j'ai pas pas même de me
promener avec une coupe de cheveux qui
dans le fond fait pas nécessairement
l'unanimité
mais sur scène c'est extrêmement payant
même chose pour lui parce que ça fait
avec mon discours un peu fou mais on se
laisse plus aller parce que j'ai cette
coupe de cheveux l'académie roi partout
j'aime vitro par le merlot apple
elle-même devant la cage du ch avec des
gogos
êtes vous comme ça dans la vraie vie non
mais moi j'ai un côté givré peu un côté
plus sérieux j'étais vétérinaire dans
mon ancienne vie je veux dire j'ai déjà
eu des conversations très sérieuse avec
des clients ou avec des animaux les
animaux un peu moi ça c'est mon
personnage les domaines non mais j'ai
fait un docteur de premier cycle j'ai un
côté sérieux qui est très développé et
jeux l'utilisant l'humour dans la
création jeu probablement de jeu dans
les très travaillant dans le milieu mais
je fais un bébé gorille td fois puis je
les tep le savant montrait que
maintenant que je suis heureux que je
fais ce que j'aime je relativise les
choses un petit peu plus mais oui pis
messages sur mon bébé bio à l'intérieur
de moosch enfant unique
puis je le sent le truc quand j'avais
pas ce que je voulais le changer quand
j'étais jeune ça sortait bassiste mon
personnage beaucoup ça en lui toutes ces
émotions sortant en colère et en c'est
tout en un peu trop intense mais c'est
ça l'humour animaux ccd extrême c'est
important c'est ce qui ferait on fait
pourrir en étant remplis de nuances on
me dit que je suis un bourreau de
travail mais avec deux enfants de moins
de deux heures comment vous allez j'ai
arrêté de procrastiner jeux pré casting
et beaucoup avant même que j'étais très
travaillant maintenant quand c'est le
temps travaillé je commence passée la
page je le sais que passer quatre heures
et demie je peux poste avec les enfants
puis jetés en famille puis le matin je
suis debout si chanceux à 7h30
sinon c'est 6h30 7h mais pour eric fait
des choses ce soir c'est quelque chose
de se lever à 6h30 les morning sun shine
si shell qui se réveille dans man in la
l'avantagent aussi de la garderie quand
et humoriste c'est que tu voles partant
garderie peu après tu peux aller te
recoucher jusque habite justement
françois bellefeuille bientôt 4h30 je
dois vous laisser aller à la garderie
merci beaucoup
ça va
[Applaudissements]